okay our last game now for today's
session I play for again ok B 6 k
check
yeah this is an idea of fun of chronic
actually who got this position a couple
of years ago by an i def 3b6 and it is
supposed to be okay for white I forgot
to of course i forgot the details of
course yeah i think it should be
something like in five he's playing
everything instantly
hmm yeah
Bishop before he still has got this
check on c5 but is it a problem no idea
what still he's got completely an awful
development yeah okay some should be
punished somehow k all night f3 you can
you can play and grab the rook in the
corner if he cancels who do have
something better even I most of the
night have threatened rookie one
yeah I don't see anything so clear cut
if I go for this one of the exchange you
got them he already has got two ponds
and these are of course week 63
not sure what you're thinking about he
needs to Castle obviously I cannot
believe that unity actually can play
something else I threaten the night
checks anyway so what else should he
play
ok
still I see no direct refutation of this
as awful as it looks maybe g3 I don't
know if you castle so now I can take
with the pawn and use this also in the
attack with f5 to come
and also the gphone is open now maybe
this was a decent idea
KO to prevent 197 rightly Stern you're
not sure how many preventing it but okay
of course you can go there as well okay
D&I g3 85 196 maybe
it can also Aztec situ with a planar g3
this list looks irritating
now he's got 25
time warning
night at five is my next move yeah young
black should be okay to just play g6 on
you
also didn't see any of this beforehand
but also working actually have an extra
point here but of course the rather
rather weak one
check check check black what if it's on
time yeah I was just going into pre-move
mode with this with this load time yeah
but why this position in the opening I
cannot believe this this looks wow you
can see six but maybe you can make and
afford this yeah come just wants to take
on f1 minus minus 0.5 here some
compensation really weird the way I
plated he was simply ok yeah well thanks
for watching and make sure to subscribe
to the channel if you like the videos
I'd like to get informed about new ones
it's totally free so it just helps them
keeping up to date with updates yeah
well bye until the next game